if you're not playing the world  championships there's a lot of people  who are saying that perhaps the world  championships don't matter anymore  do you think uh there's some truth to  that  i said that back a long time ago as well  that  for me  i don't know if  it never happened so i don't know what  would have happened but i was thinking  like the moment  that i realized that i'm not the best  player in the world like i i felt like  morally i have to renounce the world  championship title you know  because it doesn't mean anything yeah as  long as you're not the best player  so the ratings really tell a bigger  a clearer  story i think so at least at least over  time like i'm a lot more proud of  my streak of being rated number one in  the world which is  now since i think  the summer of 2011.  uh i'm a lot more proud of of that than  than the world championship  you